good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Wednesday oh my God
it's hump day hope everybody's having a
great day thus far a great day of the
week here um and speaking of great
speaking of humping and speaking of here
it's Jackie hey everyone hey how y'all
doing hey how y'all doing how how you
doing what how you doing I'm good I'm
exhausted did you know going on 5 months
of not having a sleep period of longer
than 3 to 4 hours is really starting to
wear at me no it's enough I know yeah
I'm just tired and then the story stunk
today oh no I've been searching
fruitlessly for like so long I mean I
have five stories and they're fine it
just compounded what was already an
exhausting morning let me tell you the
good
news one it's Wednesday we have dear
toaster so if the story stink like we
still have good [__] we still have good
[__] two two we can always talk about
ourselves and that's such a relief no
and it's like the stories are relevant
but still we need stories you know you
know what that's so and they're such the
stories that I choose are a reflection
of
me and when they're not giving anything
worth giving it reflects purly on your
girl so funny that you said that cuz
last night I was actually thinking like
what if just one day not forever but
like just on a rogue episode we just
like [__] the Fast Five you know
should we do it if there were to be a
day today would be the day but it
actually wouldn't because sometimes like
there's so much to talk about in our
personal lives like a Monday maybe a
long weekend and we just like have so
much to say that we could [__] the Fast
Five a little bit but I feel like today
it's just Wednesday we caught up
yesterday there's not that much new news
I mean I actually have like a major life
update to share with the group can you
share with the
class yeah do I Jackie do I look
different to you at all well you're
ranging up do oh well yeah I'm wearing
my hair in a button because it's so
dirty and I'm going to work out today
but that's not what I was talking about
well that's you do look different and
that's why yeah I guess like that is
lowkey psychotic of me um I can probably
count on my hands the amount of times
I've worn my hair up on the show in the
last seven years today is probably
number four or five but no I was talking
about my face a lot of people are
talking about like me looking really
different and I yes okay you caught me I
got a
lashlift every like few years I remember
that lash lifts are a
thing and I'm really blessed like I have
very very long eyelashes but like they
Dart straight out you would never know
they don't hold a curl well I can't even
really like mascara is like useless for
me um and I was like oh my God yeah lash
LTS let me try that again and every time
I get it I'm like I need to get on a
routine where like I make an appointment
every two months like added to my beauty
routine cuz I'm obsessed I feel
different I'm not even wearing mascara
you do look nice right but I also like
your hair up thank you I you know
actually this is a good way for me to
promote something I want to talk about
um I normally wouldn't wear my hair up
but these days you know I'm feeling very
confident I'm on this health Journey
this fitness journey and putting my hair
up for you know an hour on the podcast
like doesn't scare me as much as it used
to and speaking of health and fitness I
recorded a solo podcast I said I would
and I did and I had such a blast and 45
minutes just flew by I wasn't even you
know sometimes when you record a solo
episode it's like oh how many minutes
did I do 11 oh God did you hone your
solo podcasting skills I definitely
brushed up on my solo podcasting skills
people are kind of praising me as a solo
podcaster of our generation am I add the
job nobody said like [__] Jackie but
nobody also said like Miss jacks on this
one you know no none of you said that
can't come to your girls
defense well it's up on patreon now it
is a 45 minute question and answer for
all the questions people have remaining
about OIC and I also give an update in
me and Ben's OIC Journey because the
last time I talked about OIC and did a
whole podcast about it Ben had gone off
of it and I was still on it now I don't
want to spoil things but things have
kind of been shaken up in my home and
you know things are different I don't
want to you know I gave the patreon
exclusive I'm going to let you guys
listen so patreon.com any remaining
questions you have about OIC the journey
side effects going off anything we
talked a lot about like you know food
stuff enjoy that and if food and diet
and exercise aren't for you just don't
listen to it like you don't have to you
know make a federal case you just don't
have to listen to it just skip that one
there's going to be great stuff coming
up this month yes I'm also headed to
Mexico after this episode so
housekeeping announcement is that
tomorrow and Friday's episodes will be
Audio Only I will be bringing my
microphone with me so don't worry we're
going to take the long weekend cuz it's
Martin Luther King weekend so we're not
in studio there's no show on Monday so
hope everybody has some fabulous plans
for the long weekend I can't believe
it's like so early in the year we're
already blessed with a long weekend I
know I feel like MLK is usually like the
third like the the following week in
January and things just or maybe not but
it kind of is just sprung upon us it's
very exciting I look forward to maybe
catching up on some of the
aforementioned sleep that I've been
missing it is exciting but I have a hot
take and I don't want to be ungrateful
and I don't want to bite the hand that
feeds me cuz I'm always excited and
grateful for a 3-day week weekend but I
just feel like the placement of MLK day
like isn't ideal now I know it's like
you know out of everyone's control but
like word it up to me I feel like
there's like more dry times of year
where we have like no vacation times you
know yeah I think no federal holiday no
this is a generous one because we're
easing back into the new year and it's
like you just have to make it like three
work weeks until you get a long weekend
there is a
Darth of federal holidays in March that
needs to be solved for and we should add
one day in March cuz there's no long
weekends in March except for spring
break but like we're not Spring Breakers
sorry to say we're grown we are grown
grown but depending on how the calendar
Falls March SL April no no it's actually
usually April is like Passover and
Easter yeah so there's a hole in March
and maybe we could give some suggestions
of days that could become federal
holidays yeah what about International
turd day I like International L turd day
the feminine turd love through the
feminine gaze of the turd not not El
turd oh not El turd you know what's so
funny you know we have a list of people
like we would in a dream world love to
have on the podcast I feel like there's
five or six people Kelly Clarkson of
course Taylor Swift um for me like Kiki
Palmer has recently been added to that
list and I was thinking over the last
couple days somebody I want to add to my
personal list do you have that written
down I do somewhere I have dream guests
yeah you know I got a list for
everything t
right
right okay tell me who well read the
list to me thus far okay dream guest
here we go Kiki Palmer rup
Paul Kelly Clarkson Mindy kaing yeah
that's a good one Josh groin LOL Guy
Fieri LOL Elon Musk LOL John
Corbett John Corbett we are funny I'm
sorry we are funny okay here's who I'm
adding to and of course like the obvious
ones you should add like Taylor Swift
and any Kim Kardashian kyli yeah
yeah but no cuz they're so obvious like
OB we don't have to remember that we
want them ready I got two words for you
Jackie Jack
Black is that a good one that's a good
one Jack Black do you think Jack Black's
assistant like a toaster could help us
out it's very possible I just feel like
Jack Black is so Jack Black like lowkey
I'm so glad I brought this up Jack Black
Loki became so [__] famous like it's
insane he's like we all know him and he
could have just gone on to be like an
actor who we thought was funny but he's
in like billion dooll franchises back
toback like Kung Fu Panda Super Mario he
was just at the Golden Globes because he
was nominated for another one of those
franchises
um one of those Pixar things like oh wow
he does a lot of voice acting he's so
supremely talented he's so talented
honestly you know he would be the
perfect guest for Good Guys good guys oh
my gosh I saw Ben post yesterday a
picture of Theo and said good
boy I know good boy son of good guy I
know it was very sweet very sweet
quickly back to Good Guys the reason I
thought of it is cuz me and Ben were in
bed like two nights ago just talking and
I realized cuz I'm like I'm obsessed
with celebrities I feel like everybody
knows who my favorite celebrities are
I'm like Ben's like not really in the
Celeb space and I think I was asking him
like who's like your role model like who
do you love and he to think really
really hard long and long about it and
he said Jack Black and I'm like yes yes
no Ben is Jack Black he's Jack Black
coded yep coded you know yeah that's a
good one though yeah so anyone you want
to add to the
list I'd have to think on
it sometimes it just like pops up like
yeah where I'm like I'm desperate to ask
this pepper this person with questions
right and like Jack Black has such a
long and illustrious career like I
wouldn't even know where to begin I mean
I would of course begin at school of
rock and I would end at school of rock
too oh you would what's your like oh the
holiday the holiday is Major Jack Black
for
me shallow how sha I'm so sorry shallow
it starts and ends with shoh how like
how many that's another such a random
movie we quote all the time hey now
she's getting into my Clams Casino is
also hey look at me yes hey look at me
that's also from shallow how we were
also watching shallow how at like
literally 6 years old we like had it on
VHS it's a like that movie raised me
it's a movie with a great message sort
of yeah it kind
of like it would never get made today
but at the end of the day the message
was good it was like you know what on
the inside what counts we're all
beautiful on the inside yeah that's a
good message and like low key Tony
Robbins being a full-blown character in
that movie as himself like it was such a
good movie
yeah
WTH that's the thing about gwth she has
never missed in her entire career not
once no did anyone ever see that movie
where she plays a flight attendant with
Kelly Preston I think it's called up in
the air of course literally I think some
people would consider that like maybe
her Miss I think it's one of the
greatest cinematic achievements of our
time she has never missed she will never
miss and if gwenth palro has 100 fans on
one of them if she has one fan on one of
them and if she has zero fans I am dead
speaking of that movie someone who is
like a Jack Black comes and goes
supremely talented D DEA Mike
Meyers Mike Meyers I put in the same
category not as Jack Black close but as
Jim Carrey another great like the
greatest talents of Our Generation
really Mike Myers Jim Carrey not thirsty
Do It For the Love of the craft where
are they where are they that's a good
call that's my question what do you
think is Mike Myers's greatest cinematic
achievement because it's Cat in the Hat
awesome
powers Shrek
Shrek yeah it's like these guys n our
husbands their favorite movie ever is
Austin Paris Love
Guru is that him yeah are you sure I get
that movie confused with Don't Mess with
the Zohan oh I feel like they came out
at the same time and they were both like
dumb yeah but they're so different No
Love Guru is totally Mike Myers it's
Mike Myers yes okay um okay my bad
that's like not my genre of movie our
husbands love those movies love Ben's
favorite movie like literally is Love
Guru and I don't think I've ever seen it
no me neither but I have seen Don't Mess
with the Zohan and it's excellent
yeah yeah different yeah but I put them
for you know you just like associate two
things as the same even though they
couldn't be more different yeah you know
what I kind of associate even though
they couldn't be more different I don't
know why Love Guru and 51st
dates okay did you ever see that movie
oh no it's okay when you talk about
irrelevant movies that you associate no
no no no I'm sorry I'm sorry I was I
wasn't making fun of you I was saying
like like those two movies could have
been more different yeah I think the for
them are the are similar looking that's
right it's like two people looking at
each
other I don't know what the poster for
Love Guru looks like I've never seen it
I've got it I I just looked it yeah
there's like three people okay let me
look at 51st
AES and who's the guy oh Adam Sandler
another one yeah okay the posters are
the same it's like people sitting oh by
the way I know why you I'm sorry I know
why you like like conf conflate the two
is because Adam Sandler's also sort of
in that genre of Jim Carrey Mike Myer
jackb like supremely talented not
conventionally handsome men oh yeah not
about the looks just about the comedy
good flicks Adam Sandler's like a little
oversaturated at this point unlike the
others very commercial he's very
commercial the others are very like
scarce in their work we want
more I wanted to update um everyone from
a conversation we had yesterday when we
were talking about like you know women
being able to get away with saying and
doing crazy things a lot of people
sounded off in the comments who they
thought
was one resounding answer well there was
two actually a lot of people were saying
like Sarah Silverman Chelsea Handler no
I don't think they really do were say
anything that crazy a lot of people said
Jackie Shimmel yes that was a great
answer but people also said which I
thought was even more fitting because
Jackie Shimmel from the very get was
like [__] off I'm going to say what I
want and I'm not going to put up with
your [__] so she's never really even
like experience any sort of backlash
cuzz she like wouldn't allow herself to
but somebody who's like been through the
ringer and literally cannot be brought
down cannot be canceled they have tried
Trisha pis I saw that one too and she's
very youtuby which like theovon is too I
think that was a good answer yeah I
think that is a good answer there's not
like an exact equivalent and I think
the the the comments from yesterday just
highlight that there really aren't that
many people but I the consensus was
Jackie Shimmel yeah oh also totally
random did you see J Marie Smith is
pregnant obsessed I've been watching a
thousand videos on Tik Tok about it I'm
so happy for her oh I'm not on Tik Tok
but I've just followed her for a while
and she's been like sharing her
fertility journey and she just started
recently like sharing that she was doing
IVF and she was posting videos and who
knew that as she was posting that like
she was pregnant it does make sense that
she would only like start to share that
once she had uh you know a result but I
was so happy for her and Chelsea who's
her co-host is also pregnant again and
so they're pregnant at the same time
like podcasting Duo pregnant at the same
time I don't know it's like my dream
yeah no for
sure for sure maybe maybe in a few like
in a year in five years in five years by
Rebecca
surl um so that was just exciting you
know women in podcasting new no when I
saw that I was so happy for ji she's
also been like so open like she did I
think this was their second round of ABF
the first one didn't take and that was
like obviously devastating so I love
when people like share their Journey
obviously nobody has to share anything
especially something that's personal but
she did and I'm really happy for her I'm
really and she's been like wanting to be
pregnant for a long time and I I think
like the whole internet is happy for Jai
yeah yeah yeah I love when things happen
like that yeah when I saw the pictures I
was like genuinely shocked and and
Joyful Joyful Joyful Lord we adore this
and one thing about Jai is she's going
to take a gorgeous photo she's GNA
reinvent photography yeah she's a real
Trends setter
yes like a taste maker in the culture if
you guys maker don't know who we're
talking about her name is JC Marie Smith
J ACI I I found her on Tik Tok but
apparently like everybody's been like
following her forever for years she's a
podcast on dear media right um and she
is like an Instagram she's a
multiplatform a multi- hyet
multiplatform gly she's an aesthetic
taste she red garly she is a redhead
represent and
um that's just exciting fabulous and
she's pregnant yes uh speaking of
redheads I finished the book for the
redheads last night we are recording
today this book was so good and like
intense and just like pulls you in you
you should really read it it's called
strange Sally Diamond it's on my list
and I'm really excited for this episode
I still haven't chosen what book I'm
going to choose for the next one and I'm
running out of time the clock is running
out let me look really quickly through
my like most two two Thrillers I don't
really just want to choose an arbitrary
Thriller I no I know I don't so let me
see what I read besides Thrillers I mean
you could always always do mic the
situation I just want to say like I I
know you already did a thriller I just
wanted to add that one more time one
more
Thriller actually if you are going to do
a
thriller I think maybe a better
Thriller than Mike The Situation yeah oh
actually you should do this book even
though I feel like probably the other
girlies have read it then we can't it's
so popular none of this is
true bye Lisa Jewel
no and I know what all the girls read
because we do a segment where we share
what we've read so that it's about a
podcast oh I saw in um one of the groups
that they think it was like toast coated
and by the way like it's like I love the
redheads I'm not saying anything
negative about the redheads but you do
kind of pick like like outlier books
sometimes like this one's very on Trend
it's all over good reads and I read it
and it's actually excellent I had no
notes five stars okay I'll see if anyone
has read it and then I'll choose it yeah
I do like choosing it's always fun when
we choose a buzzy book but sometimes you
can find like a a jewel that no one's
talking about of course so good and we
can also like platform authors who might
not we have a really large audience a
lot of people are going to buy this book
it's like nice when it's someone who
hasn't gotten a lot of shine yet but
deserves it and Jackie you know how I
feel about Buzzy books like it is a
conspiracy it's industry plant like you
know how I feel but you know every now
and then it's good to be on Trend like
you were on Trend with the measure right
also some things are Buzzy for a reason
nothing was buzzier for us and fourth
wing and that's like our most listened
to episode ever we are also running you
know a non-profitable business right
right no so you're is this breaking news
redheads are not a profitable business
actually that's not true it's not true
depends you guys sell a lot of merch it
depends on the month and it depends on
if we do merch um but you know some
months the redheads is a nonprofit it's
a passion project passions aren't meant
to re generate Revenue I like calling it
a
nonprofit okay because you're like doing
a service yeah like I run a nonpr profit
called the redheads book club you have
to get your
501c3 tax um classification yeah we give
back to the
community um well while you were reading
last night I finally started the crown
oh I'm jealous I know so spoiler aler
Diana just
hey
died um and it's good I have to say like
I I actually prefer the seasons of the
crown for parts of History I wasn't
really conscious for I mean I wasn't
really alive with Diana but like I know
about it it's a part of the culture it's
Diana this Diana that there's been a
thousand movies documentaries it's like
I feel like all we ever talk about is
Princess Diana so I really I think I
prefer the seasons where I learn about
things that happen in history that I
really had no idea about yes and I think
you were the one who said this that
really put things in perspective for me
it's like when more time has passed from
that moment you know we learn more about
what actually happened people's letters
are released it's like you know journals
so I feel like a lot of the Diana stuff
is so subjective um because there's been
a thousand movies documentaries and they
all say different things yeah so I
happen to think the crown I and I don't
have no proof of this I find the crown
to be like the most legitimate and
reputable reference for for history when
it comes to the world even though
they're constantly telling us like this
is not true I know um but if what they
are saying is true and like how it went
down like those last 24 hours in Paris
like seriously jie fed like is The
Biggest Loser of all time I need to
watch it I don't want I don't want your
opinions to like color my view of it and
I want to see if like we wind up at the
same thoughts and conclusions so I maybe
I'll try and watch it tonight you know
if bedtime goes according to plan it's
such a delightful show yeah also like
not to be so annoying like Diana is the
main character I'm just like not a Diana
girl you know I feel like there are some
people especially like the gays they
love Diana like they could watch a
thousand hours of Diana I'm like really
not a Diana girl but I'm also not an
Aela Stanton girl so like I don't even
know where to look I'm kind of like
finding myself liking Prince Charles
only because like I like Dominic West
like I I hate Dominic West no now I like
him ever since he was in the Downtown
Abby 2 movie like love yeah I've turned
a corner on him too he did something
recently that was like good I don't know
what it was oh and also like his
son his son is in the crown as well
right didn't we you're lying I
thought I thought that's like what we
put together a couple months ago let's
find out Dominic West son and I don't
know the crown just like doesn't hit as
hard when the people they are portraying
are still alive do you know what I mean
yeah Dominic like William and
Kate it's weird makes his acting oh yeah
in the season before in season five the
person who plays William Prince William
is like toddler he he's like a
adolescent mhm is Dominic West son oh
that's cool I like that cute yeah yeah I
wasn't I wasn't down for them like
casting Dominic West you know like I
know Dominic West I like the crown to
introduce me to people I've never met
Elizabeth decky so when he was kind of
like a name before the crown I wasn't
down but he actually uh did good work
now I feel that way about amda ston you
know she's you know big Harry Potter
girl I don't like her as the
queen but also we have to keep in mind
the queen is in her flop era who is your
favorite Queen in terms of uh CLA Foy oh
I'm going to Olia Coleman but I also
just like loved that era of the crown
because it was so you know the most
historical and there was so much that I
didn't know and I was really getting to
know Queen Elizabeth and so like to me
Clare fooy is the queen right so like
the season of the crown doesn't feel so
much like a historical show it literally
feels like a soap opera I can't explain
it like it's just it's too current I
feel it I think that's why they
eventually stop yeah I feel like not to
be like such a hot take like I feel like
it should have ended before Diana died
cuz we all know how that goes you know
yeah that story's been told
yeah
yeah well I look forward to watching
yeah and now I think without further Ado
let's Breeze through these stories just
rip the Band-Aid off without further Ado
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know and the fast five stories
that you need to know are brought to you
by caroway as your starting the new year
do you have any new goals I do I'm
cooking I'm done ordering in saw you
cooking on Instagram it's so not
economical and it's gross like it's
never good gross how about gross and
like it's you never know what's in there
like I feel like on my health Journey
like I whenever I'm like doing really
good in my health Journey it's when I
cook and enter caroway I got the whole
shebang when I moved into my new
apartment bake wear cookware storage I
got everything you can't tell me nothing
nothing on this planet compares to
carway nobody takes better care of their
carway than me I'm like so
obsessed Caraway is non-toxic cooking
product their products are made without
any toxic materials like pfas PTF pfoa
or other hardto pronounce chemicals it's
easy cooking they're naturally slick
surface means minimal oil or butter for
slide off thepan eggs and easy cleaning
it's well- loved over 65,000 people
including Jackson turd have rated raved
and rated five stars about their carow
kitchen now it's time for you to try it
for yourself they have so many
collections to explore whatever your
kitchen aesthetic is they have something
for you brass silver gold different
colors minimalist like I got I think
it's Sage it's green with silver
Hardware cuz that's like so in my
kitchen aesthetic I got like a green rug
I'm in kind of like this green area you
guys will see when I start decorating my
apartment um so they have so many
collections there's one for every cook
visit carway home.com theeast to take
advantage of this limited time offer of
10% off your next purchase the deal is
exclusive for toaster so visit Caraway
home.com theast or use code the toast at
checkout caroway non-toxic cookware made
Modern today's episode is also brought
to you by Thrive Market again goals for
the new year staying healthy keeping a
fully stocked kitchen so you don't have
to keep ordering in enter Thrive Market
our go-to for all of our grocery and
household essentials and the convenience
of getting everything online and then
quickly Shi to our doorstep is a huge
timesaver they carry brands with highest
quality ingredients and sourcing methods
and they restrict hundreds of
ingredients across their food and
cleaning categories so we can use their
on-site filters to suit our lifestyle
needs Jackie I know you get like three
Thrive Market deliveries a week CU you
have a family of four now tell me about
that I love Thrive Market I love getting
getting my groceries online I love not
lugging huge bags home from the store
and I love that everything on Thrive
Market is like vetted as a healthier for
you option made with good ingredients
organic clean so you don't have to like
go scouring through the ingredients and
make sure there's nothing nefarious in
there so you can shop easily with clear
conscience you can sort by dietary
preference vegan plant-based whatever it
is that you like and they really have
everything I was just doing my Thrive
Market shopping yesterday I'm excited
for some tasty treats when you join
Thrive Market you're also helping a
family in need with their one forone
membership matching program so you join
Thrive market and they give join in on
the savings with Thrive market today and
get 30% off your first order plus a free
$60 gift go to thrivemarket.com theeast
for 30% off your first order plus a free
$60 gift that's t r i v market.com
theeast thrivemarket.com
thee toast great thank you la you're
welcome PA our first story some legal
news Todd and Julie Chrisley receive a
one million settlement in a lawsuit
alleging misconduct in the investigation
against them question mark yeah Todd and
Julie Chrissy have scored a legal
Victory amid their ongoing prison
sentences for their involvement in
multi-million dollar bank fraud and tax
evasion scheme on Tuesday a lawyer for
the couple announced that they are
receiving a $1 million settlement from
the state of Georgia to resolve their
2019 Federal lawsuit against Joshua
weights the former director of special
investigations of the State's Department
of Revenue we have been saying for
months that the criminal case against
the chrysle was highly unusual and had
real problems the family attorney said
this settlement is an encouraging sign
he said it's nearly unprecedented for
one arm of the government to pay money
to defendants when another arm is
fighting to keep them in jail right
after being cleared of their state of
tax evasion charge in Georgia Todd and
Julie took legal action against weights
in October 2019 for specifically
targeting the famous family in their
state tax evasion charge according to
the lawsuit which was in tamed my people
the reality star's former lawyer said
that weight's initial charges against in
Julie was a shocking example of how an
outof control public servant can abuse
his office and violate the rights of
innocent citizens for reasons that have
more to do with securing publicity and
money for his office than with enforcing
the law but the thing is is no matter
his motivations for bringing charges
like if they did that [__] they did that
[__] so the fact that the government
paid them a million dollar settlement a
settlement is really an admission of
guilt so I feel like there's more here
I've always felt especially when it
comes from the government who can afford
to keep this going forever know
sometimes people settle because they
can't afford the legal fees afford the
fees and the time and the energy and
it's like you know what I just want to
be done with this like right I will
settle but the government doesn't have
those Hang-Ups no and I I definitely
have felt like the chrisly case is
bizarre because you know they got more
jail time than a common criminal like a
rapist it's I got 12 years which is
really a lot for a financial crime which
is really a victimless crime because
they were just you know taking some
banks to the
cleaners but I I I do believe that they
did that [__] though you know but I do
understand because I'm always seeing
clips of like Savannah christle like she
has a podcast and she talks about this
every single week like she is not
letting this go she's really really
feels like I think her family has been
wronged and honestly this you know news
story does help her case yeah that this
person like abused their power and even
if they did something that you know it's
not to the extent that it was
prosecuted so heavily so and good on the
Christley for like continuing the fight
but like I don't know I wouldn't be
spending my energy on like trying to get
a settlement from the government I'd be
trying to get my sentence commuted you
know I guess but this boodes well for
their entire case I think yes it's true
it's true step one perhaps there was
some corruption and I don't know the
extent of what they did in the extent of
you know what was nefarious in the
justice department but now I'm like
maybe the Christley aren't so bad right
maybe the Christley need to be
Vindicated perhaps
so I think it's good I mean also a
million dollars is great always good a
million dollar especially I'm sure they
worry a lot about like being in prison
and their kids and they have grandkids
and like they're they're I think all the
kids except for Grayson are not minors
and now Savannah is like the parental
Guardian for Grayson but still you have
to worry about your kids you know
Financial Health and their ability to
you know make but they work and and
they'll be right but no I'm saying
getting a million dollars is probably a
huge you know sigh of relief for the
christly parents who are in prison
unable to provide for their children and
grandchildren yeah cuz you know they
took in custody of one of their
grandkids Chloe yeah who's really young
so like they have they have
dependence always good to get a million
dollars never ever ever
hurts I mean you say that but I'm sure
there could be a situation let me ask
you a question how much money would
somebody have to pay you to spend an
entire year in
prison
and let's say it's not like a maximum
security scary place it's not it's kind
of like where Teresa Jud
went a lot cuz it's not just about like
the time in prison it's time away from
your family like missing
life so how
much and I'm saying like
taxfree 50 million oh my god really what
about I was going to say 1 billion 1
billion
yeah and then I was thinking well if
somebody offered me 500 million I would
obviously say yes but honestly like am I
crazy like I don't think I would do it
for $100 million like it's so I'm so
afraid of prison it's like so my number
one fear um no I don't think that's
crazy but you have to like then also
think like you know $50 million would be
lifechanging so for one year like yeah
no and like I guess like you're thinking
about your kids so of course like I'm
just thinking about me yeah like we
could get
a house a
plane you can get a lot of things not
enough though maybe 100 not that's what
I'm saying 500 yeah agreed okay are you
ready for our next
story Miss drama Selena Gomez abruptly
quit social media again after the drama
of Kylie and Timothy and she so uh
Selena posted that she is leaving social
media saying focusing on what really
matters I'm off social media for a while
and it was a photo of her boyfriend
spending um quality time with some kids
and she's just like that she's gone
again okay we'll see you in an hour
Selena um she also posted commented on
an Instagram post about the drama yep
because he news had posted about like
the lip reading did Selena say that this
and this and she wrote no I was telling
them about two of my friends that had
hooked up okay I am more uh certain than
ever that she's lying cuz that's like
the worst lie
ever and like we all know Kelly said
with Timothy so like stop lying yeah no
but also maybe she's talking about her
two friends that hooked up Kylie timy oh
oh yeah yeah yeah like maybe she thinks
it's not a lie she was talking about two
friends who have hooked up Kylie and
Timothy yeah I will say like Selena
Gomez's social media behavior is not the
best and this is just another example of
you know of that because she will be
back and it'll be sooner than you think
yeah
and that's that's so
selener it's this Instagram she can't
quit she can't and that's relatable sort
of but I just want to say like that
comment I think really didn't help her
case they they really just shouldn't
have said anything because we could all
just wonder we would never know we would
never have hard cold proof but her now
saying not only were we not saying that
but I was talking about two of my
friends who hook up like no you weren't
and now you also like look like a liar
no you weren't like stop it's bad to lie
and like for people to know that you
told a lie yeah it's so clearly a lie it
just like really hurts your credibility
yeah cuz then it's like what else is a
lie yeah no by the way like this was a
bad move that comment was bad and maybe
she got yelled at and that's why she
said she's taking time off of her phone
yeah maybe maybe yeah
but certainly yeah that's like so basic
like what were you asking about oh just
like two of my friends who hooked up
like tell me you're put on the spot and
lying without telling me but like she
wasn't even put on the spot because
nobody expected her to respond like she
no of course these are aess celebrities
they're entitled to have a conversation
that stays in private right and we can
all just live in one speculate yeah
that's our job and you like responding
is beneath you yeah well our next story
is very related because another
conversation that people think they know
what was said that's going viral from
the Golden Gloves is between Emily Blunt
and John krinski have you seen this
about the the weather about the weather
and now she last night attended the
governor's Awards alone after her
conversation with John had gone viral a
conversation that fans are speculating
is either about divorce or the weather
yes so fans are speculating what Emily
Blunt and John krinski were talking
about while posing for photos on the
2024 Golden Globes red carpet Sunday I'm
sorry it's insane that like two people
especially like two married people like
can't get a moment a modum of privacy
like agreed but why would they get
privacy on a red carpet no I know but
like just in the digital age the fact
that they can't have like a 10c exchange
without it
being dissected to it's just like it's
really crazy yeah so who would want to
attend an event like this a few theories
have come to the Forefront of the
guessing game with some people saying
that he's looking to split from Emily
yes they said I've watched this 500
times trying to convince myself he said
something other than divorce they say I
swear he's saying divorce um but I that
he um then other people are saying I
can't he said I can't wait to get
indoors yes so yes it does look like
he's mouthing the word divorce but then
in the whole clip when somebody uh
transcribes their entire conversation
they are talking about the weather and I
saw a lot of people commenting on the
weather at the Golden Globes it was so
windy like it was cold so I really do
believe I don't I I don't think these
two are getting divorced like period And
I also don't think that's what they were
saying and I think if they were getting
divorced they wouldn't like mention it
on a red carpet they're not a bunch of
but now and she would have just went by
herself by the way because he wasn't
nominated and like it's not common for
like a woman or an actor to go by
themselves to an award show that only
they're nominated for yeah but then she
went without him last night so people
are like is there a divorce
actually I don't think so also because
them yeah no I actually was thinking
about them while they were on TV I mean
John Kinski seriously should go to jail
for his outfit but I love these two and
I can't think of a couple I think more
evenly
matched in terms of level of Fame and
success and like respect like they're
both so well respected I actually I
think maybe she's a little bit more no
no the office people love him I know
jackar in the office like but he's kind
of TV and she's kind of like Silver
Screen you know no they're really great
and I think they also lift each other up
and also like for the stability of the
realm like these two can not get
divorced like people would not be okay
for the stability of the realm yes no
you're right people wouldn't be okay and
it's nice like God my God like there's
so I can't even count on one hand like
the amount of age appropriate long-term
relationships in Hollywood like this is
good [__] yeah no they are
holding holding up the industry they're
holding up the realm they're holding up
the realm for there's like a couple
couples that like people would not
Kidman and Keith Urban no that's really
just us no I'm telling you people love
them it's not just us Lake Lively Ryan
rolds I don't feel feel that way not
personally but but the people the realm
they the people's couple they are they
are I personally like don't ride or die
or ship for them but I understand why
people do yeah and again it's like a
well-matched you know age appropriate
couple We Stand We Stand yeah lot to
kids very you know share a lot on social
media like we know what's going on they
leave like funny comments oh see
actually Ryan Reynold social media
behavior is part of the reason I don't
stand him as a couple yeah but also
because we don't watch that
movie which you know the one Ant-Man no
Deadpool Deadpool is he even in Ant-Man
I'm not sure I think he plays Deadpool
in someone else's movie of Ant-Man okay
here are some like married long-term
couples in Hollywood that I think people
love they love Tom Hanks and Rita Wilson
yes for the stability of the realm yes
for the sub of the realm um David and
Victoria Beckham yeah they should get
more credit than than they do I agree
this is a good one like everybody loves
Goldie and Kurt yeah everybody loves
that they keep the realm stable yeah
they are one loadbearing wall of the
realm and and people who aren't um into
like the idea of marriage love Goldie
and Kurt because they've been together
for like 50 years but never legally
married and they're like see Goldie and
Kurt did
it oh here's another one the classic Dak
Shepard and Kristen Bell classic classic
another one Kevin Bacon and Kiera
Sedwick very good um Nicole Kidman and
Keith Urban are on this list uh Faith
Hill and Tim MRA that's good I feel like
they don't get enough credit either they
don't another one that I don't feel like
is holding the realm together but it's
nice that they're still married SJP and
Matthew brck agreed like if they got
divorced no one would care the realm
remains unharmed but we should still be
more impressed than we are about how
they fared yeah oh Cindy Crawford and
Randy Gerber very good oh my God
not Jada pinket Smith and Will Smith
being on this list no they are not
holding up the round also this list
needs to be updated because Hugh Jackman
is still on here and we know he's
getting divorced and they were never
holding up the
realm who him and his wife Deborah Lee
Fess oh oh I forgot who we were talking
about yeah yeah
yeah okay I feel like I got them all Oh
Ellen and Porsche oh no I don't feel
that way about Ellen Porsche but Beyonce
and Jay-Z yeah oh this is a good one
Freddy Prince Jun and Sarah Michelle
Geller I forget about them they do their
part they do their part and they I feel
like I like I love them and they're like
legitimizing all the work of the 90s you
know the fact that they're still
together it was all for something Alicia
Keys and swiss I'm good without I'm good
too but wait here is this is this would
shake up the realm a lot Shake It Up The
Realm Shake It Up Chicago Leslie man and
Jud appow yeah yep yep yep they're
that's exactly of the elk that's of the
elk yeah that's it yep I got it list
done that was fun that was fun I love
lists wait should we make a list like
celebrity couples that would shake up
the realm if they got divorced that's
good because there are probably more
than that what that list has off but
we're talking about a very specific type
of couple and you were right like Blake
and Ryan
celebrity divorces that would shake up
the realm but I feel like I don't I
won't to search that but I'll I'll put
it in I need all my my search
words okay John and Emily Blake and Ryan
lesli
and is that it that there was one other
couple in there that oh Dax and Kristen
yes so
classic I stand by Nicole Kidman and
Keith herbin but if you it's up to your
discretion if you want to put them on
the list just don't think people like
have enough taste y to feel as strongly
about them as we do that's fair that's
totally fair they're kind of like our
little thing yeah like we kind of
invented
them yeah are you ready for our next
story speaking of couples yeah Simone
biles is on the cover of Vanity Fair and
her husband is giving a few quotes
including insisting again that he had no
clue who she was before they met but how
does he explain his tweets where he
literally says her name he doesn't but
he say but a lot of people don't believe
me when I say I had no clue he said um
at the time he was at a training camp at
his alma mater and he wasn't time she's
been famous for like 15 years in 2016
when of her Olympic success in Rio okay
okay okay um and that he wasn't paying
attention to the Rio games he said quote
I never once was like oh let me check
gymnastics out he noted that he only
caught some basketball and a bit of
track he quickly learned when he found
her on Instagram I was like man she has
a lot of followers she must be pretty
good okay I just want to say like it's
really hard for any like living
breathing American to not know who
Simone bil is let alone an athlete I'm
sorry I'm just not buying this but he's
doubling down I unless he said like I
grew up on a ranch without electricity
and no internet or television okay then
those people I could I believe them when
they say they don't know who he said
when she won the Olympics I was in
college and we didn't have NBC we didn't
have Olympics channels and we were in
training camp in Late July early August
so I'm not pay the amount of details the
amount of details I know he's lying I'm
sorry he's
lying I don't think he's lying this is a
crazy thing to lie about twice and now
in Vanity Fair not just like an off-the
cuff more mark on a podcast I think he
said it people were so shook by it that
he gets asked it now and he has to
double down because if he admits he's
lying it's really weird also we didn't
have NBC isn't that like basic cable
first of all literally everyone has NBC
unless you didn't have a television but
which case you say I didn't have a
television but also it's like streaming
what about social media this day and age
and I'm sorry it's not like Simone biles
only exists on Channel 4 like she's
everywhere weedies you know it's like if
you follow ESPN on Instagram because
you're an athlete and you care about
those things then like Simone comes up
on your feet sometimes and I like how he
was like I mean yeah I watch Like
basketball but how'd you watch
basketball if you didn't have NBC right
nobody's like I watch basketball like
putting down gymnastics when gymn like
who the [__] watches Olympic basketball
nobody everybody watches NCS [__] yeah
but Simone is unbothered by him and his
comments and she loves him and she's
standing by her man and that's great but
it's giving jealous wouldn't you be duh
that's like me marrying Joe Rogan like
you think I wouldn't be mad every day
you'd be like I never heard of him until
we matched Ona ex that's by the way it's
the exact same thing yeah I have spoken
about Joe Rogan he has spoken about
Simone biles but then 10 years 10 years
later would be like me saying I have no
idea who Joe Rogan is you guys pulling
up this clip you would say I don't have
Spotify right
right so anyways she's looking gorgeous
on the cover of anity
fair I love her by the way this I this
is not a reflection of her if you love
her you kind of have to love him because
a she does equals b and b equals c no
but it's like she's on the cover of
Vanity Fair why the [__] is her husband
getting a quote like can she like have
her cover maybe she she seems like she
wants to bring him into things and yeah
I guess I guess for him to have his
shine yeah no it's good it's good it's
sweet of her yeah and I guess like if I
was on the cover of Vanity Fair and like
Ben obviously came with me to the photo
shoot and they asked him a question I
would be like yeah that's fine yeah no
be like no don't talk to him you never
know that is something I it's not like
you know someone gets a lot of press so
maybe if it was like your first big
thing you say shut up and like to her
it's like oh sure whatever another cover
it's true another cover yeah another one
another one I'm so glad we're out of
that DJ khed Snapchat era like that was
a really annoying time it was but we got
some like really good quotes from it
like I love another one and I love love
major key I love major key and I love
business is
booming was that him yeah that little
sneaker kid that he used to like go and
see and he say how business and he say
business is boomman boomman yeah by the
way I never even watched GJ KY Snapchats
like this is what I got like filtered
down to me regurgitated pervasive it was
yeah no he really like was the culture
for an entire year another
one
obsessed obsessed and also like major
key it was a major key there's so many I
say major key all the time yeah I you
know what I say all the time TJ CID do
you that's what I say literally never
done once in my
life are you ready for our and final
story I am Jennifer Lawrence is dish
dissing dishing which one dissing or
dishing dish on her stressful wedding
day so Jennifer Lawrence opened up about
her 2019 nuptuals while walking the red
carpet at Sunday night's Golden Globes
admitting that she found being a bride
to be quote awful she said God thank you
for someone saying it she said she
mostly worried about the guests having a
good time which made the entire day so
stressful she said so you're spending
all this money for other people you're
not having fun you're just like is this
person having fun the private ceremony
was attended by celebs including Robert
dairo who had worked with Jennifer on
Silver Linings Playbook American Hustle
en Joy but at the rehearsal dinner she
admitted that she was so worried that
dinar wasn't having a good time that she
even told him to go home LOL I looked
over and I saw Bob who doesn't know
anybody and he's kind of wandering
around and I immediately was like no
this isn't what he wants to be doing I
don't want him here so I went over and
whispered I was like go home and he was
nice he like talked to my parents and
was polite but I was just like go that
just genuinely made me feel better
that's funny yeah yeah no I mean
everybody has their own Robert Dao you
know obviously hers is on a bigger scale
um but I'm so glad someone's finally
talking about it cuz like I'm really
sick of like the yasif foration of brid
hood it sucks yeah it does it shouldn't
have to be that way and I hope that but
no everyone's on there unless it's like
your second wedding everybody Le to
learn by experience nobody can tell you
to like stop and and dial it back and I
like imagine people who have been
married more than once say that their
second weddings are so much better than
their first yeah but then oh I'm sorry
uh Taylor shriker yeah but also I feel
like a lot of people have second
weddings that are much smaller it's yeah
because they realize it's not that
important and like what what's worth
spending money on is like the people the
food yeah like no but I'm saying for the
actual budding budding of the wedget
wedding budget the actual budget of the
wedding like you know what to spend
money on what not to spend money on
what's stupid what's not stupid like I
feel like a second wedding is such a
Vibe yeah but then it's always
surprising to see people who have a
really big second wedding yeah that I
feel like you didn't learn but no but
it's like well now that I found the
right person like I still want all the
theatrics I know but like the theatrics
aren't worth
it yeah but when done like you really
could it's a great time like I had a
great time at my wedding I had a great
time at your wedding too cuz I was I
like I had a
like all the stress was beforehand and I
didn't let any stress like reach me on
my wedding day I was like we're throwing
a party and I'm going to have fun and
and you're going to wear this hat to the
party tonight you know it you you know
it so they're remaking Wicked and if
that line doesn't make it into the movie
like I will be going on stri did you
know that the Bridgerton oldest son is
in
Wicked
the yes yes I did I learned that from
the golden Globes yes yes yes I didn't
know that he is so
hot and so gay it's just not fair I
wonder who he's playing him and Matt
Bower like it ain't right I don't know
who he's playing I feel like he's
wearing his hat to the party tonight no
is he playing Fiero Fiero and then who's
SpongeBob
playing I feel like SpongeBob is
literally an extra like he's not even
he's a character actor like he's
literally uh a munchkin yeah Jonathan's
playing
Fiero and who is SpongeBob
Fiero let me pull up the IMDb for Wicked
no I'm telling you like SpongeBob plays
like the janitor at the school that they
meet at like it's sh University like
he's literally the smallest character
he's okay so we know oh he plays Bach
who is Bach um he's not ringing his name
is ringing a bell oh is is he the one
who she sets up her sister
with I'm not going to lie like I need to
refresh my Wicked he's the munchkin
lander man what did I say munchkin who
was alphaba and Glenda's friend during
their time at
shiz like I said he's a munchkin yeah I
do think he gets together with the
sister and then that's why she's like
you should wear this hat to the party
night something like
that um those are the Fast Five and we
interest
I think I saw Wicked once in the way I
Remember by the way I was going to say
like how do you I've seen Wicked like
four times like the last time was like
maybe two years ago like and I I I know
alphaba Glinda and the wiard you did see
it recently yeah with Jessica Vos she
invited me backstage and pained my hand
green and I got to go like on the stage
and stuff I haven't seen it since
childhood but really so much of it stuck
with me Kett I stand there with the
wizard feeling things I've never felt
and though I never show it I'd be so
happy I could melt and so it will be for
the rest of my life and I want nothing
else till I die held in such high esteem
when people see me they will scream for
half of O's favorite
team the
wizard
h no that was so good let me also say
since quitting my VAP I can sing so much
better well there's a reason and I just
want to say I'm N9 days clean no fuckups
wow and I just want to say kayala
settles in the wicked movie oh [__] me
up so now you know it's a party [__] me
up Kaa where the H is she been she's
been working on the wicked movie she
should have been in Bean girl musical
yeah she should be in every musical no
ever since that movie came out grest
showman if you're going to make a
musical and Kaya settles is not involved
like pack your bags pack your things
back to drawing board aita Zayn
[__] also Jeff Goldblum is the
wizard that's a good cast love there's
some good castings here Michelle yo is
in it oh no I forgot to put on deodorant
today oh good thing we're almost done we
have deer toasters great our weekly
advice segment that is brought to you by
neutr
Fall listen hair thinning shedding any
sort of hair issues it's very common
lots of different reasons I exper I I
thought I was like above it I was like
that's never going to happen to me like
the one thing I have in this life is my
hair cut to literally my hair like
brushing it and so much coming out I
realized I was experiencing hair
shedding I had never even heard that
term before um and I reached out to my
community and I said what are we doing
for hair thinning shedding and everybody
said neutraal I had seen it online
before and I know like people have had
success with it but what the amount of
people who told me to use it and who
have had great success with it was
really reassuring so neutr fall is a
proactive approach they target the root
causes of hair thinning any sort of hair
issue and that could be due to a lot of
different things for a lot of people
it's you know for Jackie it was post
post thank you I'm like what's the word
postpartum for me it was change in diet
change in lifestyle hair loss there's a
million reasons stress and so neutral is
going to Target the every the root cause
of your issue nutral is a number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement they have over a million
people that are seeing thicker stronger
faster growing hair with less shedding
you take a 3-minute quiz it'll determine
what the underlying root cause that is
keeping you from reaching your hair
potential they'll analyze your lifestyle
biology hair history as well as
environmental triggers then they'll
create a hair health plan that is
tailored to your hair needs start your
hair growth today by taking neutri
Fall's hair Wellness quiz and get your
personalized hair health plan today for
limited time neutral is offering our
listeners $10 off your first month
subscription and free shipping at Nutri
fall.com
quiz when you enter the promo code the
toast take the quiz get started reaching
your hair Wellness goals with neutral
today neutral nut R
aol.com quiz promo code is the toast
neutr fall.com quiz promo code the toast
all right dear toasters our weekly
advice segment where you girlies can
write in about anything and get advice
from us if you've always wondered like
what would Jackson Claude think now is
your opportunity there are two ways to
submit dear toasters gmail.com that's an
email account we will keep all of your
information Anonymous also if you go to
the toast podcast.com and scroll down
there's a little submission box that
says to your toasters that is completely
Anonymous write Us in let us know what's
going on about anything in your life
from work to relationships to sex to
pregnancy whatever it is we keep your
[__] Anonymous and if you've written Us
in and we haven't read it on air here's
what might be happening one your
submission might be too long we try and
keep it like a paragraph at most you
know two your situation might just like
be uninteresting and that's something I
can't help you with ready yes hello
Jackson Claude my husband's family has a
few rental properties all of which are
in a five M 5 mile radius from our home
a new renter who's a single mom around
our age recently moved into one of their
rent rentals when she first moved in
there was something wrong with the water
heater so my husband's grandparents
asked him to fix it and he did since
then she has been texting my husband
directly for any and every little
convenience she texted about seeing a
rat in the kitchen taking out the trash
a few other things I'm not entirely sure
how she ended up with his number but I
digress I'm not usually a jealous person
but I find this inappropriate and a
little disrespectful I asked my husband
why doesn't she call your family who
owns the house with the issues and he
says it's not a big deal because he
would be the one to fix that stuff
anyway she's just cutting out the
middleman I I think messaging another
woman's husband is not okay am I being
insane a little bit just a little it's
not about like messaging another woman's
husband it's like it's right she's not
thinking let me text this girl's husband
she's thinking let me text the renter I
me let me text the landlord the person
from the family who comes and fixes
things and like it's just the most
efficient person to text but I also
understand why that is annoying for your
life to have this like woman who's
constantly like telling your husband to
come and do this and that and this and
that and it's like J isn't that like a
part of your husband's job is not is it
it is she said like normally like a
tenant would text the grandparents and
the grandparents would send her husband
so he's going anyway but she by the way
if somebody if my landlord was like all
right I'm sending over JN to fix the
stove and John comes over I'm getting
John some like it's always John coming
yeah in the future I'm just texting John
directly yeah so I think you need to
change your mindset of being like she's
not texting another woman's husband in
her mind she's texting her landlord
handyman like that's fine but you know
you always you always got to keep an eye
out for hot young thing I I I think
that's very important you know girls can
be very uh treacherous and uh fortuitous
so always you know keep an ear out for
like what's going on especially some hot
young thing moves in and your husband's
going over there all the time but I
don't think you immediately need to be
like this is inappropriate it's really
not inappropriate yeah it hasn't become
inappropriate right now it's just
business but that is annoying no but
keep bothering your husband about it
push him right into her
arms yeah keep bothering
him yeah so you're being a little crazy
like like a little bit like these are
things you think to yourself and you're
conscious of but you never say out loud
you know yeah you don't have cause you
have literally no cause so you do look
crazy until you have cause so you keep
an eye out to look for
cause um are you ready for our next one
mhm hey girly swirlies love you both
dearly so I live and die for smutty
romance novels but lately it's been
making me unrightfully annoyed at my
boyfriend I know it's psychotic to think
that my boyfriend could be a man written
by a woman but like effort never hurts
right I've brought up that I really want
to be complimented given flowers taken
on dates Etc multiple times and still
nothing changes I know it's because of
my smut books that are making it seem
like all men are perfect but it's
starting to really upset me that mine
isn't do I put the books down or the man
please feel free to rip me apart I have
to say I'm so glad that you wrote in
about this because I think that this is
a universal experience two things can
happen when you're a girl in a
relationship with a smut book and I just
want to say it's not one of the the
other both can happen at different times
one and I've heard that's very common is
like it reignites a flame in a
relationship it gives you new ideas like
it's been actually very good your
husband buys you more smut novels that
can happen yeah but it can also and for
me like I have had this where I'm like
Ben you have literally never put your
hand on the small of my back like the
tiniest things because that's what the
smut writers do they like really
romanticize the most random small
innocuous thing not like oh let me buy
you a house with filled with roses like
obviously that's like obvious it's the
little things I'm like Ben how come you
have literally never ever once like put
your hand on small in my back like so
it's either can happen yeah and I
totally normal I do think it's normal
and the men in these books are perfect
and they're written by women like they
are not real and it's not fair it's
never going to happen it's not fair to
compare your relationship to the
relationship from the book so I think
you need to take the books fiction you
need to take the books out of it and
look at your relationship on its own now
if this person's your boyfriend and
you're not going on dates like that's
not right you should go on a date
sometime I don't think you need to put
the boyfriend down but I do think maybe
a little work on your relationship
couldn't hurt yeah yeah just you need to
take a step out of like the smut
Universe for one second and think like
what like is what you're asking
unreasonable what are you asking are you
asking for like a little bit more
romance that's totally fine but are you
asking for things like are just not in
the male like the capability of a man
like you need to understand if you're
being unrealistic in your expectations
yeah but just know I just want to say
and I need people to sound off in the
comments like I have heard like I think
this is extremely common yeah it's fair
to want a little more yeah of course and
like a book making you see that isn't
wrong yeah but it's he's not going to be
you know but you can't
compare a fake man to a real one you
can't especially a fake man written by a
woman who like knows no no for the sole
purpose of like romance I think we
should start reading like romance novels
written by men so we can uh no thanks
get some reality yeah it's just going to
be like
[__] you think no are there romance
for swi manam you knew what I was saying
that's I do but can you repeat that I
think everyone knew are there romance
novels written by men I'm sure that they
are out there I have never heard of one
I've never seen another human being
reading or recommending popular
successful good
the okay
no just like it's for the girls it's for
and by the girls like please [__] off I
feel like like like they're going to see
you know women like Colleen Hoover Tessa
Bailey Lucy score like making a lot of
money and like now men are going to try
[__] off like can we have one thing yeah
but I do think sometimes I feel that way
and that's why sometimes I can't read
these books it's like so unrealistic and
like I
know it is
unrealistic yeah but that's why we love
it yeah that's true but not if it's
affecting your real life in a negative
way a negative way right because people
read fantasy books like iron flame and
no one's expecting like a dragon to take
them to work the next day like you
understand like this is fantasy yeah you
have to go into smut with that
understanding as well yeah it's true I
am obsessed with our third and final
dear toasters like you you couldn't have
written a dear toaster more perfect for
me okay okay I consider myself a pretty
traditional girly I've always envisioned
taking my husband's last name when I get
married now I have fallen in love he is
an absolute P jom we're getting married
next year just one tiny problem his last
name is dudy no how do it spelled D o o
d
y he said that it would mean a lot to
him to get his for me to take his name
but come on duty am I just being
immature and should suck it up or should
I Stand My Ground and not be named after
feces for the rest of my life
help I mean no I'm sorry like absolutely
not you can't take this name it's so
obvious and two like I'm not even a big
fan of like name taking I never thought
I'd become like one of those girls like
I'm not a fan of it yeah I'm not a fan
of it in practice cuz it's just like
really inconvenient you know you've
established yourself your entire life
and it's not even about like
the the Dynamics or the politics of it
it's like the
convenience well I feel both ways it's
incredibly inconvenient yes to have to
like reintroduce yourself to the world
Midway through your life well not Midway
like a quarter through your life depends
on when you get married and no I'm
talking about like yeah I'm going to be
one of those like patriarchy Queens like
no I don't [__] with like it's [__]
like I have to change my whole name
identity everything I've accomplished my
family history for you who are you yeah
and especially if I don't subscribe if
your name is in an upgrade and it's a
downgrade Duty oh yeah I happen to to
love my last name also I actually really
like saur so if I had to take it I
wouldn't mind um and I'm sure I I'll
feel differently like when I have kids
like I'll I'll want to have like the
same last name as my kids but do you
really want your kids having the last
name Duty like talk about bullied kids
are [__] cruel but what do you do
about that you're just giving you're
handing it over the kids name is going
to be Duty
no okay let's talk about like a hyphen
what do you do Dy about it let's say her
last name is like Sterling I don't know
I'm just making this up I like that I
like it too um Sterling
Duty let's hyphen it but some people
hyphen and like cut the name in half I
agree but Let's sturd do let's take a
step back and look to the newly wedded
kayn Miller keys and Dean Urt who now go
by the last name Belle yeah they gave
themselves a brand new name that but why
just because your husband's last name is
Judy you have to give up up your own
name like that's [__] why could be
Kuma like fresh tabula rasa something
new for the both of us and I think Belle
is either Dean's mom's made a name I
believe I don't jack I don't know if
we've ever used the phrase Kuma fresh on
the toast before we have to explain what
that means oh it means like it's yish it
means like comes fresh fresh it's it
kind of gives like tabul rasa energy
like that's what I just said Kuma fresh
tabularasa oh but I think of Kuma fresh
always like when I put on a fresh pair
of under wear like after like a workout
or like something really sweaty in a
shower I'm Kuma fresh I mean all the
time I'm Kuma fresh yeah change the
sheets Kuma fresh oh Kuma fresh yeah
even though in my house they're called
Fresh cakes oh yeah in my house they're
called um
crap [__]
what oh my
god oh
great what
I
ordered a
dresser on Wayfair
approximately let me tell
you what's today's
dat on November
2nd on November
30th it was attempted to be delivered
and I have tried ever since November
30th 1 2 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 times to get
this [__] dresser delivered there has
been an issue every single time one time
the Certificate of Insurance was wrong
second time the dresser came and it was
broken third time the delivery people
were like sorry the weather we're
skipping you always an issue today I was
the day and they said oh between 10 and
12 I'm like of course like the two hours
a day I'm completely unavailable so I
said during the toast I'm not going to
put my phone on do not disturb I'm going
to wait for their call and I'm going to
get this dresser [__] delivered I
missed the
call n to be the dresser was delivered
yay do have a picture I do I do I do
send to me back to what we were
saying
oh take a note out of kayin and Dean's
book that's my advice oh yeah come up
with a new name I'm sorry like you
shouldn't have B is Dean's mom's made a
name honestly I think that moving
forward instead of just like aut ially
taking the husband's last name I think
we should sit down like have a really
honest conversation about a whose name
is better mhm B whose family history
sorry is more impressive agreed C like
who's accomplish more C what letter of
the alphabet do we want our kids to be
stuck with like a lot of things I'm
sorry like we just need to be more
honest and dudy is never going to win
Sterling is going to win yeah Duty's
never going to win unless they're up
against
diarrhea I think I would almost prefer
diarrhea let me tell you why CU it's
like cuz you cuz you could say it's
diara whereas like dudy is Judy there's
no alternate pronunciation it's like
very phonetically you know singular
diaria yeah and the word like it could
be in another language like something
beautiful it kind it's like it's the act
that makes it gross but it could be like
French
for
Rose
it could be French for
Rose and if you say it with an accent
like you're
golden Thea and that's something that
like over time could be spelled
differently I think that's what happens
to last names over the years they like
get changed that happened at Ellis
Island 100 and there are like cultural
factors that change last names forever
families that have you know Hundred Year
history they come to Ellis Island it's
chopped in half it's changed it's made
to be like more Anglo and I think we're
at that kind of time in history right
now where it's like gender Dynamics are
changing why should the woman always
take the man's name let's make a change
love love love love I love that di
diaria it is
diaria thank you to everyone who wrote
in just a reminder dear toasters
gmail.com is where you can submit we're
running low on submissions because like
honestly not to be rude like some of
them stin so send us some new
submissions either deer toaster
gmail.com or our website the toast
podcast.com thank you to everybody who
wrote in also if you've written in
recently and we've read your submission
on air and we gave you advice and you
either took it or chose to ignore it
which is totally fine send us an update
what what went on what happened right in
the subject line update so we can find
it um that's our show tomorrow and
Friday's episodes are both podcast only
so YouTube girlies GE your loins thank
you so much for listening to the
toast thank you so much for listening to
the toast londay Morning Show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every Monday through Friday
and YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as podcast anywhere
podcast found Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio i r cast box all the places
wherever you listen to podcast find us
the toast leave a five star riew about
how beautiful studing and wickedly
talented we are hope you guys have an
amazing incredible beautiful starting
and smart day and we'll see you tomorrow
love you love you
bye